[Aplausos]
[Música]
si la banca está protagonizando una de
las crisis más salvajes de todo este año
2022 y no será porque no hay candidatos
tan brutales la historia que podríamos
decir ya que es la argentina asiática
todo el país está en bancarrota y eso
significa que los estantes de las
tiendas están vacíos que cinco de cada
seis hogares andan escasos de alimentos
y que es más el 22 por ciento de la
población es decir 5 millones de
personas necesitan urgentemente ayuda
alimentaria el combustible por supuesto
también escasea es más los rilán que se
han tenido que hacer colas de más de 3
días simplemente para poder repostar
también para poder cocinar el gas estaba
precios exorbitantes y eso sí pueden
conseguirlo los cortes de energía en
este país son de hasta 13 horas que por
supuesto están paralizando a las
empresas los exámenes se han aplazado
por falta de papel y los hospitales de
todo el país también se están quedando
sin medicamentos pero lo peor de todo
esto es que la crisis de ser blanca es
una crisis anunciada
y ella se lo que estaréis pensando
muchos pero vamos a ver fonseca y a mí
qué me importa la crisis de
la ncaa es que ni siquiera sé dónde
están en el mapa no sé ni cómo
pronunciarlo pues pues y lo cierto es
que si sabéis dónde está si blanca es la
isla de ceilán esa isla del índico que
está siempre ahí debajo de la india pero
toda esta crisis debería importarte
porque podría suponer una noticia
excelente para la política militar china
y en consecuencia podría ser algo muy
preocupante para la india y el resto del
mundo y diréis pero qué tiene que ver
una crisis de ese de la ncaa con el
ejército chino al final de este vídeo lo
entenderéis todo pero además lo que está
pasando ahora mismo en sir lanka es
también una fábula sobre qué puede pasar
cuando un país tiene un gasto público
desaforado y cae en un endeudamiento
masivo es algo así como un aviso para
navegantes así que la pregunta es pero
qué tiene que ver la política de
seguridad china consideran acá cómo es
posible que sirvan acá que nunca ha sido
un país especialmente pobre al estilo el
congo ha llegado a verse en una
situación así cuáles son las medidas que
va a tener que tomar el gobierno para
salir de esta crisis hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
llega un momento en la vida de un hombre
en el que se tiene que depilar ahí abajo
y créeme si os digo que no os recomiendo
que utilicéis una maquinilla normal
haced lo que queráis pero un amigo mío
lo intento y desde entonces le llamamos
el castrato hasta aquí puedo leer dicho
de otra forma que sólo hay una opción
realista para poderse depilar en esas
partes tan delicadas más que en este
paquete en el paquete de landscape se
incluye esta maravilla que es el lawn
power o el cortacésped que con su
tecnología única skin safe evita que nos
cortemos tranquilos no os voy a hacer
una demostración delante de la cámara
por supuesto el land mower se puede usar
bajo la ducha bajo el agua ningún
problema man scape se puede mojar además
esta maquinilla tiene una lucecita que
podéis ver aquí que nos ayuda a ver
mejor en las partes más oscuras de
nuestro cuerpo y además tiene un travel
lock para cuando nos vamos de viaje pero
no sólo eso además de esta maquinilla el
paquete de mans cake incluye una
veladora para los pelos de la nariz la
llamada with cracker o rompe hierbas que
la podemos utilizar para la nariz además
también en el paquete se incluyen los
desodorantes diseñados para la
entrepierna el crok de server que veis
aquí y el club rival ver que ahora que
llega el verano os vendrán especialmente
bien y como siempre tenemos un descuento
muy especial para todos vosotros que
seguir visual política básicamente si
utilizáis el código vps conseguiréis un
20% de descuento más el envío
internacional gratuito vamos que estéis
donde estéis podéis recibir más skate
más un boxer y un neceser de regalo
recordado amigos más que las
herramientas perfectas para proteger
vuestras partes más preciadas y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
el sugar daddy del clan rajapaksa
los rajapaksa han dominado la política
de sir lanka durante los últimos 20 años
su líder martín da rajapaksa lo ha sido
absolutamente todo en este país insular
parlamentario ministro líder de la
oposición y primer ministro hasta que en
el año 2005 fue elegido por fin
presidente de sir lanka para entonces el
país llevaba dos décadas sumido en una
guerra civil contra los llamados tigres
tamiles imaginaria pacsa inició su
presidencia con una ofensiva brutal
contra esta organización separatista el
ejército de si blanca contó en ese
momento con la ayuda de china y en el
año 2019 alcanzaron la victoria total
como os podéis imaginar este hecho
multiplicó la popularidad de los
rajapaksa del presidente en agilidad
pero también de su hermano gotabhaya que
dirigía con puño de hierro el ministerio
de defensa así que como ya os podéis
imaginar en las elecciones del año 2010
arrasaron la oposición no tuvo ninguna
opción y eso que no pudieron encontrar
un mejor candidato miras este hombre que
veis en pantalla se llama sarath fonseka
con cada visual político pero no os
aseguro que no tengo ningún parentesco
con él ahora que bien pensado ahora que
tengo una mans kate pues a lo mejor me
puedo la puede utilizar también para
afeitarme y dejarme una cosita así a lo
rodolfo y me presento a las elecciones
en sí blanca a ver qué pasa en el caso
es que después de 26 años de guerra
china ofreció sus yuanes para financiar
la reconstrucción del país y los
rajapaksa lo vieron como la gran
oportunidad para hacer realidad todas
sus fantasías y diréis pero cuántas
fantasías tenían los hermanos a pacsa
pues muchas y no precisamente baratas
en 2012 empezó la construcción de la
logia ward en colombo con 350 metros de
altura esta torre de telecomunicaciones
es la segunda estructura más alta del
sur de asia costó más de 100 millones de
dólares y fue financiada por el eximbank
de china y ojo porque china también
aportó los 8 millones y medio de dólares
necesarios para construir el teatro en
él un poco una ma jin dar la pasa a
mayor gloria del entonces presidente de
soy la ncaa estas cantidades son
anecdóticas las comparamos con los más
de 200 millones de dólares que costó el
aeropuerto internacional raya pacsa de
mátala porque hay a quien no le gusta un
aeropuerto con su nombre fue en 2013 por
el apenas transitan 90 pasajeros diarios
y su actividad continúa generando
pérdidas por supuesto también fue
financiado por china
y aquí es donde os presento un concepto
revolucionario en diplomacia y
relaciones internacionales lo que
llamamos la diplomacia sugar daddy un
sugar daddy es alguien que te paga a
todos tus caprichos a cambio de favores
de todo tipo pues bien china se
convirtió en el sugar daddy de ese gran
casino pagó todos los lujos de un
dictador un poco gold digger con
caprichos caros el problema el problema
es que en esta vida todo tiene un precio
y cuál es el precio a pagar pues aquí es
donde entra el puerto de hambantota
[Música]
un manto está no es precisamente una de
las ciudades más importantes de sri
lanka pero qué casualidad sí que es la
zona de la que procede el clan de los
raya pax ya ubicada en el sur del país
hammam tot albergaba un puerto que
apenas tenía tráfico marítimo sin
embargo fue el lugar elegido por
rajapaksa para construir un macro puerto
de aguas profundas china llegó a prestar
más de mil millones de dólares para
construirlo y en 2017 firmaron un
acuerdo por el que una empresa china se
quedaba con su explotación en exclusiva
y con el 85% del rendimiento del puerto
durante 99 años y diréis qué interés
tiene este puerto pues desde un punto de
vista comercial el puerto se está
convirtiendo en un importante enclave
para el comercio energético ahora bien
desde un punto de vista geopolítico la
perspectiva militar puede ser aún más
interesante
como sabéis china antagoniza con la
india y la india controla casi todo el
océano índico y quisiera podría bloquear
la mitad del tráfico comercial que llega
a china sin embargo si china pudiera
tener un puerto militar en sí de la ncaa
la situación cambiaría drásticamente
sería algo así como tener una base
militar en este país el problema es que
en principio convencer a sir lanka de
que te deje construir una base militar
es prácticamente imposible a no ser que
te conviertas en su sugar daddy
entendéis la dinámica pues tranquilos
porque no somos los primeros que nos
hemos dado cuenta
maithripala sirisena denunció que sri
lanka estaba controlado por una familia
y que el país se dirigía hacia una
dictadura de una corrupción y nepotismo
desenfrenados y diseñadas las elecciones
presidenciales en el año 2015 en un
principio sirisena suspendió la mayoría
de los proyectos de la era ralla pacsa
por sospechas de corrupción sobreprecio
y por burlar los procedimientos
gubernamentales
[Música]
sin embargo en cuanto a este buen señor
puso un pie en el gobierno 100 y senna
reanudó todos los proyectos con china
porque
pero esperado un momento porque los
programas en sí blanca no dejaron de
crecer en el año 2019 este país vivió el
peor atentado islamista de su historia
269 víctimas mortales en varios
atentados simultáneos las cosas no iban
bien por el país así que los franceses
volvieron a las urnas y esto es lo que
ocurrió
gotabaya rajapaksa jura como nuevo
presidente de sri lanka a pesar de todo
su historial de corrupción y nepotismo
los ciudadanos de ser blanca apostaron
una vez más por los rajapaksa vamos que
hablamos del sueño de los kennedy hecho
realidad gotabaya rajapaksa presidente y
su hermano martín dar a pax a esta vez
como primer ministro bueno y por
supuesto sus otros hermanos basil y
chamán son ministros de finanzas y
ministros de agricultura y a su sobrino
nam al ministro de juventud deportes y
bueno también el sobrino yo sí está como
jefe de gabinete vamos que todo queda en
familia es una familia especialmente
corrupta pero que sabe ganar las
elecciones con este panorama que podía
salir mal pues como podéis imaginar
absolutamente todo ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
la caída del imperio raya pasa
el ataque yihadista de 2019 tuvo como
consecuencia una gran caída del turismo
la llegada de extranjeros de serón
ancash se redujo a la sexta parte de un
día para otro por el miedo a los nuevos
atentados para que os hagáis una idea el
mes anterior al ataque llegaron 240
4.000 turistas mientras que durante el
mes posterior apenas fueron 38 mil al
margen del impacto que unos datos así
pueden tener sobre el crecimiento
económico del país lo más importante es
que dejaron de llegar divisas pensando
bien antes del atentado el turismo traía
cada año a la isla unos 4 mil millones
de dólares esta reducción de ingresos en
ser blanca coincidió con una política
del gobierno que no suena nada mal
porque gotabaya rajapaksa impulsó una
bajada de impuestos estimada en 2.200
millones de dólares el problema el
problema es que esta bajada de impuestos
se produjo en el momento menos adecuado
para las finanzas del país porque se
blanca dejó de meter dinero en el tesoro
público justo antes de que comenzara la
pandemia del cob y 19
al igual que en medio mundo la pandemia
fue un shock para las blancas los
diferentes confinamientos para
protegerse del virus para realizaron la
economía local y redujeron los ingresos
del país en 8.600 millones de dólares
además lakovic 19 fue un nuevo torpedo
contra el turismo las ganancias del
turismo cayeron de
4.380 millones de dólares en 2018 apenas
500 millones después de dos años de
pandemia
con este panorama las principales
agencias de calificación redujeron el
rating del psir blanca a 'bono basura'
esto hizo que pedir prestado en los
mercados globales fuera prácticamente
imposible para el gobierno de sir lanka
un país que ya de por sí estaba bastante
endeudado llegados a este punto los
rajapaksa decidieron salir de este
callejón sin salida como les gusta hacer
las cosas a la familia rajapaksa es
decir en familia así que rajapaksa
presidente habló con rajapaksa primer
ministro y llamaron al rajapaksa
ministro de finanzas para decirle
escucha brother cuánto bony nos queda en
el banco central nueve mil millones de
dólares en divisas
suficiente así que ya sabes tire de ahí
para tapar agujeros el problema es que
estas alturas si la banca ya era
directamente un queso gruyère en el año
2021 empezó a verse una señal de que
algo raro estaba pasando él seguirá
blanca y es el caso de la agricultura
orgánica
[Música]
de la noche a la mañana el gobierno de
sri lanka anunció su gran apuesta por la
agricultura orgánica esto implicaba una
prohibición tajante a nivel nacional de
la importación y el uso de fertilizantes
y pesticidas como resultado de esta
política la producción nacional de arroz
se redujo en un tercio y la producción
de té la principal exportación del país
y fuente de divisas se redujo en un 16
por ciento presionados por los
agricultores los by apacsa tuvieron que
dar marcha atrás a esta medida en menos
de un año
y como os podéis imaginar esta reducción
de los beneficios de la industria
agrícola coincidió como ya hemos visto
en otros vídeos de visual política con
una subida internacional de las
commodities porque entre febrero y mayo
de este año 2022 el precio del
combustible en sin blanca como en el
resto del mundo se ha disparado en un 38
por ciento y como pagan las
importaciones de petróleo pues con
soluciones tan creativas como éstas
giran acepta tomar té de sri lanka para
saldar una deuda de 251 millones de
dólares en petróleo lo rajapaksa
utilizaron los 9 mil millones de dólares
que tenía ser el anc en divisas para
seguir pagando su deuda sostener el
valor de la rupia local y garantizar la
llegada de las importaciones pues bien
en abril ya sólo habían pulido todo todo
absolutamente todo y la rupia se devaluó
rápidamente y perdió casi la mitad de su
valor respecto al dólar estadounidense
el gobierno anunció entonces que
suspendería los pagos de los 51 mil
millones de dólares que se banca debe a
los acreedores extranjeros conclusión
pues que las importaciones se congelaron
[Música]
y esto implica que se disparó el coste
de todo desde alimentos básicos como
puedan ser el arroz las lentejas la
leche en polvo el azúcar hasta los
medicamentos la escasez de combustible
unida a la sequía provocó continuos
apagones de electricidad muchas empresas
dejaron de trabajar de la noche a la
mañana y nos encontramos por tanto con
una economía paralizada por el peligroso
cóctel sin la pnc es es decir deuda
elevada moneda devaluada escasez y un
ingrediente que actualmente abunda en
todas partes inflación la inflación de
sri lanka se dispara a un récord del
68% en julio seguro que ahora tendréis
porque llevamos medio año viendo
manifestaciones multitudinarias en si
blanca el presidente gotabaya rajapaksa
recurrió al ejército para callar las
críticas pero no consiguió absolutamente
nada porque cuando los manifestantes
prendieron fuego a las casas de algunos
ministros empezó a destituir al resto de
los rajapaksa para calmar a la turba y
quedarse él en el poder pero como lo
daisy blanca no se arreglan dos tardes
los manifestantes asaltaron directamente
el palacio presidencial en el momento en
el que hacemos este vídeo gotabhaya
rajapakse está exiliado en singapur y
sus ciudadanos están arruinados para dos
generaciones y la pregunta es cómo puede
salir si es blanca de esta crisis pues
atentos
[Música]
el retorno del sugar daddy
alrededor del 45 por ciento de la deuda
decir blanca es con inversores privados
el resto se debe a diferentes países e
instituciones multinacionales entre las
que destacan el banco asiático de
desarrollo con un 16 por ciento mientras
que a japón china y el banco mundial
corresponde un 10 por ciento cada uno
ahora así blanca tiene que renegociar
las condiciones de los préstamos o
buscar que sus acreedores les perdonen
una parte de la deuda y aquí el
escenario se complica para la nación
insular y grace porque pues porque lo
más probable es que los inversores
privados no estén dispuestos a perder ni
un céntimo y bien que hacen de hecho
algunos como el hamilton reservan han
llegado a emprender acciones legales
para cobrar su deuda pero es que luego
está china que ya ha rechazado
reestructurar la deuda desde entonces
las negociaciones se volvieron un
poquito más discretas hasta que en este
mes de agosto hemos vuelto a tener
noticias de que exacto del puerto de
hanban total barco de vigilancia chino
listo para atracar en ree lanka se puede
usar helio and one 5 para espiar a la
india la respuesta es que sí y lo que es
más importante esta es una señal de que
algo está cambiando en la relación entre
china y sir lanka
[Aplausos]
porque la gestión del puerto de hammam
tota fue concedida a china por 99 años
con la condición de que no le diera el
uso militar de hecho en 2017 ya negaron
la entrada en el puerto de un submarino
chino pero claro hoy en día la posición
del gobierno de sir lanka es mucho más
débil y ya me diréis vosotros como
negarle a to sugar daddy que uno de esos
juguetitos de submarinos y tal entre en
jan manto está cuando al mismo tiempo le
está rogando que se olvide de tus deudas
está claro que si la banca no está en
condiciones de negarle nada a china y el
nuevo presidente range we care messing
tiene claras cuáles son sus prioridades
en estos momentos atento primer plano
del jockey and science web de
la mls del iec y en el momento lo que
hacemos este vídeo sir lanka está en
negociaciones con el fondo monetario
internacional para pedir un rescate pero
el nuevo gobierno no lo va a tener nada
fácil a nivel interno porque las medidas
que se están tomando son extremadamente
impopular es es decir subida de
impuestos recorte del gasto público
privatizaciones pero es que a nivel
externo las negociaciones van a ser muy
pero que muy duras es poco probable que
el fondo internacional ofrezco un
rescate a no ser que china perdone la
deuda
el problema china tampoco está dispuesta
a crear un precedente pensad que china
ya ha prestado un montón de dinero a un
montón de países en desarrollo si de
repente todos estos países se hacen
impagos chinas se vería con un problema
financiero super gordo dicho de otra
forma que sólo hay una cosa que se
blanca podría hacer para ablandar el
corazón de china y eso es ceder el
puerto dejando está para su uso militar
esto significaría que de repente china
podría tener una base militar al lado de
uno de sus principales antagonistas la
india y por tanto os podéis imaginar
quién está haciendo el mayor esfuerzo
para sostener así blanca en estos
momentos tan aciagos india apoya a sri
lanka asegura el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores destaca la ayuda de 3800
millones de dólares a la nación insular
este año el problema para india es que
por sí sola no podrá solucionar los
problemas de si blanca sí que tiene
pinta de que esta crisis ofrecerá
novedades en los próximos meses
estaremos atentos en visual polític pero
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que occidente debería ayudar así
blanca para que no caiga aún más en las
redes chinas o pensáis que no debe
preocuparos que china imite a eeuu y
despliegue bases militares en el
extranjero podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos este canal y
dadle la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
se ha gustado este vídeo dadle al like y
nos vemos en el próximo un saludo y
hasta pronto
[Música]